We've always wanted a voyage to the moon, what an adventure, going back in ancient times.
Go again with these Greeks.
Yes, you're right.
The Greeks dreamed of a tornado carrying a ship to the moon.
Around the year 1000, the Persian king, Caicos, had another idea.
Go gather eagles.
These of law.
169, Galileo observed the moon with a telescope.
Creators.
Mountains.
In 1700, the Englishman David Russon had an idea.
Detail for imaginary vocible. Why?
It wasn't powerful enough.
They couldn't aim it accurately.
It's just too far away.
Yes, but there's another reason.
Shooting a cannon is too strong. The projectile is too fast. The men inside would be crashed.
That is the precise answer. To date, in any known technology, there is only one way to send human beings into space safely, and that's rockets.
The first to achieve this was a Russian, Konstantin Chalovsky.
The moon is 380,000 kilometers from the Earth and circles our planet every 27 days. You, the distance.
A long way.
Yeah, a long way.
Anyway, you'll never get there.
I was listening to what I said. Konstantin?
You said it's 380,000 kilometers away, and so one day man will get there.
Regarding distance, you are right, Constantine.
But how would you suggest we get there?
Using a rocket, sir.
Jules Verne already wrote that hydrogen and hydrogen form an explosive mixture.
There is combustion, and the hot gas is directed back away using a tube,
propelling the rocket forward.
He discovered everything.
He did the calculations, but it's always the same story.
No one was at all interested.
But just a few years later, an American, Robert Goddard...
That one didn't work, but I know what I'll do!
Oxygen and gasoline, that should work!
Right, let's try it!
This day is truly historic!
We are going to perform the first test of a liquid-powered rocket!
Only watch it, Robert, it might explode!
Liquid-fuel rockets wrote a new chapter in the story of astronautics.
Spaceflight.
But guarded remained almost unknown.
Meanwhile, in Europe...
...the test...
Von Braun, could you make a rocket?
If in time, it's possible.
Then make one, and quick!
Range of more than 300 kilometers, a gyroscope, and a guidance system.
To see a terrible weapon, the Nazis lost the war.
After the war, it began. The race to the moon, the race to space.
Of course, everyone needed the German rocket technicians.
We lost the war.
Just when our rockets with the 4,000-kilometer range were almost ready.
Simple.
The Russians are that way.
The Americans are that way.
Where do you want to go?
To Siberia or to Texas?
To Texas!
Oh, you prefer Siberia.
No, no, Tima, I made a mistake.
If you're to Texas, I wanna go to Texas!
The great match would begin between the two most powerful nations in the world, the United States and the Soviet Union.
Nikita Khrushchev, champion of the Soviet Union.
My right, the President of the United States, Dwight Eisenhower.
Khrushchev to serve.
The Soviets placed a satellite in orbit and it's circling the Earth.
One, love.
The Soviet Union puts Sputnik 2 in orbit with a dog aboard.
Two to nothing for the Soviet Union.
Mr. President.
Flora, the first American satellite, is put in orbit.
Two to one.
Autovarist.
First pictures from the hidden side of the moon. Nice, aren't they?
4-1 in favor of the Soviet Union. Khrushchev to serve.
I write the new American champion, John F. Kennedy.
7-2 in favor of the Soviet Union.
The Soviet Union. Gagarin and Titov, the first men in space orbit.
Two American launchings that do not achieve orbit.
Still, two points. 9-4 for the Soviet Union.
Is that all?
American astronauts in orbit and Mariner on its way to Venus.
The first woman in space is Russian, Valentina Tarechkova.
An American, Gordon Cooper, circles the Earth 22 times.
American champ, Lyndon Johnson.
What do you want, Comrade Leonid?
No, it's my play. I take your place.
Net!
Go away.
A new champion for the Soviet Union, Comrade Leonid Brezhnev.
Snapshots of the moon might interest you.
We took him from our satellite that's going around the moon.
The Soviet Leonov is the first to go for a spacewalk.
It lasted 10 minutes, and then an American, white, took one for 21 minutes.
The first round is won by the Soviet Union, 2114.
Merci beaucoup.
This is our first satellite in orbit.
There were dozens of various satellites in orbit going around the Earth.
It had been sent to Venus, Mars, even to the Sun.
No one had ever walked on anything other than the planet Earth.
Not so far.
Neil Armstrong had been chosen for the American space program.
He will go down in history as a great explorer of the modern era.
We have to approach and then dock.
Preparing for docking, over.
Operation a success. We appear stable.
Engine fired on its own.
Round like a...
Have to disengage.
I've got to find a way or we won't make it.
Approaching the Pacific.
Shook up.
Turned Earth's atmosphere.
Getting very hot, but we're okay.
This space race match is becoming very exciting.
This game will be decisive.
Piece of the moon?
It's a promise, Mark.
Time for you to get up.
60 seconds and counting.
T-minus 50 seconds.
Heart rate, 75 per minute.
All systems are go and counting.
Astronauts ready.
10 seconds.
Nine, eight, seven, six, five, four, three, two, one, zero.
Mission.
Second station.
It's in Earth orbit.
Destination.
In a weightless state.
Separate third stage.
The maneuver to turn us around.
Attaching the litter module.
Mission completed.
Eagle is attached to command.
Do something, the sun will roast us like so many chickens.
Give us a little spin.
Three rotations an hour.
Still, Neil, you're about to be a TV star.
Full star, Sirius Vega.
The computers taking our bearing were precisely 255,000 kilometers from the moon.
Let's sleep.
Look at that!
Accelerate.
Fifteen hundred kilometers.
You will be hidden from Earth over the hidden face of the moon.
Engine ignition to achieve lunar orbit.
Our speed?
Eight thousand kilometers an hour.
Seven thousand six.
Five thousand eight hundred.
You are in orbit.
Checking out systems on the Eagle.
Buzz, let's do it.
Systems are go.
We can separate lunar module.
Ready to release in ten seconds.
Nine, eight, seven, six, five, four, three, two, one.
Releasing now.
It's free.
Eagle, do you read me? Eagle, do you copy?
Roger, loud and clear.
All systems are go.
The Eagle has wings, ready for moon landing.
Now is when the crucial decision has to be taken.
Then there was no going back, all or nothing.
It had to be perfect the first time, otherwise.
Otherwise what?
Otherwise they were lost.
They couldn't get back, not enough fuel to return to orbit.
Nobody could ever go and rescue them.
For them, it would be the end.
All systems go, activating engines to leave moon orbit, descending.
Zero two.
Saturated. Directing us toward a crater full of rocks.
The computer couldn't take any more data.
In a few seconds, it's moon landing.
Great boulders. The moon module could overturn.
A catastrophe.
Only one solution. To act quickly.
Now switching to manual control.
It's our only chance. Quick, find a landing site.
Looks good over there. Three degrees left.
Not over there, not too bad.
We'll go for it. Don't have much choice.
We'll run out of fuel.
Sweat. Too much dust.
Can't see anything. We're going to land.
Touchdown, cut the motors.
Mission Control, Tranquility Base.
The Eagle has landed.
Sea of Tranquility.
We could use a little Tranquility right now.
Right, Collins?
More precision.
We don't know, I'm afraid.
You don't know where?
Mission Control calling Collins.
Do you read me?
Loud and clear.
The module.
Down on the moon, I guess.
But where, Collins, where?
I don't really know.
Stay in contact, Collins.
Negative, entering shadow area of the moon.
Come in, Collins.
Come in.
There's no point in trying.
He's behind the moon.
From there, no contact can be made.
We've lost them. They'll die on the moon, and they'll know they're going to die.
We'll find them. A lunar map.
Oh, wrong one. And not that one.
They're here. Collins will check it.
Collins is still behind the moon.
To wait.
Me.
Roger, Collins. Loud and clear. And you?
Five by five.
Okay, we want you to check. We think they're in the West Crater about 500 meters in.
Are you sure?
Sure.
Okay, I'll take a look.
Guess we'll be needing a shave soon, huh?
Right, to work. Full checkup, okay?
Systems are go. Electronic circuits, pressure, oxygen, cooling system, TV transmitter.
We put on support system. We need these to survive on the moon.
So we can breathe.
Refrigeration, check.
Communication, check.
Ventilation, check.
Pressure, check.
Dehumidification, check.
Purification, check.
Okay, let's take a walk, all right?
And open the hat. We're all set.
Wait, just a second. Pressure's still too high.
This is it. You say you've got us watching at home.
Look, children, the moon, humanity's dream for millions of years, you realize.
And now, for the first time, a man will set foot on the surface of the moon.
Supposed to say, uh, one small step for a man, giant leap for mankind.
I guess I kind of like what he said there.
All over the world, hundreds of millions of people were glued to their TV screens.
Americans, Russians, Chinese, Indians, Eskimos, people in Africa, Puan, and the French, the Italians.
1901, the United States of America wins.
Were they able to come back?
Yeah, of course, safe and sound.
Did he bring any moon rocks back?
Many of them.
And the space race, wasn't it?
Well, the truth is, everybody did.
After the race to the moon, many countries decided to work together to pool their efforts
in the conquest of space, and it's going on today.
The astronauts of tomorrow, eh, maybe you'll be among them.
Des mondes meilleurs, des vagabonds tout ailleurs.
Voici que l'homme décolle, il va quitter le sol,
mais pas dès qu'il s'envole d'autres firmaments.